Berlin is the German city with the
largest number of startups 29 company
founders per 10,000 residents success
depends on the attention I get in the
customer feedback the rest is as random
as the weather tuck in the covers and
next please rishaad Equis is waiting for
customers just lie back like you're
watching TV and off we go chauffeurs
visitors around Berlin on his bed bike
he thinks the German capital is the
perfect place for such outlandish
business ideas Berlin is by far the most
diverse city in Germany and so rich in
contrasts so lots of people are drawn
here Berliners are going to launch an
unusual project and really has to stand
out a trip on Rick's recliner rickshaw
costs 45 euros per hour but you can't
argue with the originality of this
one-of-a-kind bed on wheels and this is
just one of many creative fantasies
coming to life in the German capital I
think it's because so many young people
live here once they are keen to try out
something new that's how you get such
great ideas like this bed bite I don't
find it strange I think it's really
creative and it's fun Berlin is the
perfect place for fun and humorous ideas
here's another one this isn't street
cleaning its street fashion on manhole
covers for the last eight years mfon
syrup has been using them as printing
patterns for textiles plenty of crazy
people are doing great things and there
are lots of creative characters here and
that gives you more incentive to try out
your own ideas
after studying textile design Emma
started printing t-shirts from manhole
covers in her second home portugal but
it didn't hatch into a business idea
until she came to Berlin today she sells
her so-called stolen prints at craft
markets and boutiques can you live from
this slowly but surely yes I can't live
off of it I do it part-time and work my
normal job the rest of the time but it's
enough to keep me doing Berlin
horizontal so a whole fleet of bet bikes
down the road perhaps that's not the
point
Equis likes his idea of his one and only
rickshaw considering the investment and
the expenses I'll have to add up at some
point I might be in for a rude awakening
but it's all outweighed by the fun I
have doing having fun and earning while
you're at it not a bad deal for Berlin's
adventurous entrepreneurs